Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
This episode is brought to you by audible.
Audible has the largest selection of
audio books on the planet and I've used
audible for many,
many years.
I have several books to
recommend right off the bat.
Ready player one by Ernest Cline,
the Tao of Seneca by Seneca.
If you want to hear my favorite letters
of all time put into compensation the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman.
If you're a nonfiction purist and
you want something to convert you,
this is one I've listened to multiple
times and right now if you're curious,
I'm listening to nonviolent communication
by Marshall Rosenberg and you can tell
which one is the correct one because
it has a peace sign on the cover of the
audio book and it's five
hours and nine minutes long.
This was recommended to me by
Neil Strauss multiple time,
New York Times bestselling author and
audible has a lot going for it right now.
Among other things,
this is time sensitive.
Amazon prime members can get
audible for just 495 a month.
That's $4 and 95 cents per month
for the first three months.
That's like getting three months for the
price of one and after that it's just
1495 per month.
This offer ends July 31st,
2018 to claim this offer.
You can go to audible.com/tim or text
Tim Tim to 500 500 to get started.
Audible members get a credit every month.
Good for any audio book regardless of
price and unused credits rollover to the
next month.
If you don't like I give an audio book
that you've purchased or that you've
selected, you can exchange
it with no hassle whatsoever.
Plus your audio books are yours to
keep forever. Even if you cancel.
Audio books are a great sidekick,
a great secondary activity for any number
of things you might do this summer,
like hiking, sunbathing, hanging out
on the beach, running road tripping,
whatever it might be.
Hiking outside.
I listened to audio books a lot when I'm
going on. Long walks, dog walks, cooking,
et cetera. Even working out
in between sets and so on.
And if you're someone who likes to binge,
this offer might be a good time to
start a series like game of Thrones,
Harry Potter, Outlander. The
list goes on and on. So again,
simply go to audible.com/tim or texts
Tim Tim to 500 500 to get started today.
Amazon prime members can get audible
for $4 95 cents per month for the first
three months.
Once again,
that's like getting three months for the
price of one and after that it's just
1495 per month.
This offer ends July 31st,
2018 check it out.
Okay.
Hello,
this is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss Show where it is my job normally
to deconstruct world class
performers through interviews,
whether they're from business,
sports, entertainment, military,
otherwise to tease out the habits,
routines,
favorite books and so on that you can use.
In this episode,
I'm going to let someone else do
the heavy lifting and he's very,
very qualified.
Reid Hoffman on linkedin
and Twitter as Reid Hoffman.
Rei is a frequent flyer
of sorts on this show.
He is often referred to as the oracle
of Silicon Valley by tech insiders who
look at his company building and investing
track record with all the companies
include Facebook, Airbnb, Zynga,
flicker, and many, many, many others.
Read is well known as the
CO founder of Linkedin,
which has more than 300 million users
and sold to Microsoft for 26 point $2
billion. Prior to that, he was
exec vice president at paypal,
which was purchased by
Ebay for 1.5 billion.
And at paypal he was nicknamed firefighter
in chief by the then CEO Peter Teal,
who's also been on the podcast and read
is widely considered one of the most
successful angel investors
of the past decade.
He's now a partner at Greylock partners,
a top tier venture capital firm.
And on my phone there are
very few podcasts that I
listened to multiple times.
There are very few podcasts that I
recommend over and over and over again to
other people,
especially entrepreneurs.
And what I'm going to showcase in this
episode is a conversation between read
and uh,
Brian Chesky who is a
cofounder and CEO of Airbnb.
And there are a couple of other cameos
and I'm doing this for a number of
reasons.
Number one,
if you want to learn how to scale your
company from whatever the number might be,
200 million, 200 million users, uh,
paradoxically you can increase
the likelihood of success
by doing things that do
not scale.
And this is a really critical concept
to understand and it's best done through
examples and that is why I want
to showcase this discussion,
which is from the first season
of masters of scale and I really,
really hope you enjoy it.
Uh,
I loved it and Joe Gebbia,
cofounder of Airbnb has been on this
podcast before and we covered his
development as a designer and an
entrepreneur leading up to the original
development of the
business model for Airbnb.
That was part one and
I promised a part two.
So this is in some ways that part too.
Exactly.
And a masters scale is a great show.
If you haven't seen it, it, uh,
showcases famous founders and
innovative leaders and so on,
sharing their lessons for success.
And there is a brand new
season out right now.
The new season includes
episodes with of Spotify,
Instagram, taskrabbit's, shake
shack, and glossier among many,
many others. You can subscribe to master
the skill on apple podcasts or learn
more@mastersofscale.com
so without further ado,
please enjoy this short
episode with Reid Hoffman,
Brian Chesky and many others.
And if you've heard me recommend
1000 true fans to you many,
many times before as the
article you should read.
If you're only going to read one article
on marketing, which is by Kevin Kelly,
you can find it on kk.org this
is the audio compliment to that.
So with much further ado, much
further ado, what much further ado,
please enjoy.
Joe and I are broke.
We're losing weight and I didn't
have a lot of weight to lose.
You know those binders that you put
baseball cards and we've a credit card to
them at this point.
I am $25,000 in credit card debt.
Joe's tens of thousands
dollars in credit card debt.
So this is like make or break.
We need a lifeline
that entrepreneur and need of a lifeline.
That's Brian Chesky,
cofounder and CEO of Airbnb.
A service that lets you rent a couch
for the night or a cabin or a castle.
Today AIRBNB is valued at $30 billion.
Eight years ago,
a very different picture.
We had this website and maybe 50 people
a day are visiting it and we're probably
getting like 10 to 20 bookings
a day. So, and by the way,
didn't work out for a year and a half.
So for anyone who's worried your company
as an attraction, that was our traction.
It was 2008 and election
year in the United States.
Barack Obama was running
against John Mccain.
You needed the tax code that Brian was,
that the Democratic national convention
hatching a PR campaign for Airbnb when
they could rescue the company
and their credit card bills.
Joe and I look at each other and we said,
we're air bed and breakfast.
Air Beds aren't going so well. Maybe
breakfast. We'll as we thought,
what if we could sell breakfast?
Maybe we can make some money.
What's a nonperishable breakfast cereal?
And so we thought the
presidential campaigns coming up,
we just launched at the DNC.
What if we created a Barack Obama
themed breakfast cereal? We thought,
what would it, Barack Obama
themed breakfast, he'll be called
Obama o's, like Cheerios, the
breakfast of change. We thought, well,
we want to be a nonpartisan website,
so we'd also have to need a John Mccain
themed cereal and that's a no brainer.
John Mccain was a captain, the
navy, and so we came up with
Captain Mccain's like captain crunch,
a maverick in every bite.
We ended up making a thousand boxes
of collectible breakfast cereal.
We sold them for $40 a box.
That's $40,000 not bad for pocket change
and it got them through a cash crunch,
but it came at a cost. We
had to physically make the
breakfast show ourselves,
meaning we get a printed poster board
and we had to fold it and hot glue it.
No one told me I had Haku breakfast
here and they should call it burn glue
because every time you get on you,
you burn.
You and I had the perfect one to one
ratio of burned a box and so I literally
had to hot glue 1000 bucks a sterile at
one point in the middle of the night.
I remember meeting, I wonder if when
Mark Zuckerberg started Facebook,
he had the hot glue breakfast cereal.
The answer was no,
and this was not a good sign,
but what was a good sign was Brian's
willingness to work with his hands,
Burns and all.
I'd argue that painstaking handcrafted
Labor is actually the foundation of his
success. In order to scale,
you have to do things right
that don't scale. You got to have
incredible talent at every position
there are fires burning
when you're going out
such an idiot and when you go back to
this is totally going to be amazing.
There are so many easy ways to do.
I have no idea what it is.
Sorry we made a mistake, but
you have to time it, right?
Nepal, 10 years later, I can
say you do it. Just do it.
This is masters of scale.
Yeah.
I'm Reid Hoffman, Co, founder of
Linkedin partner Graylog and your host.
On this episode,
I'll make the case that the only way
an organization can truly scale is the
first two things that don't scale at all.
I'll try to prove that theory through
stories from some of the smartest
entrepreneurs I know over the last 20
years I've worked on or invest in in many
companies that scale to 100 million
users or more. But here's the thing,
you don't start with 100 million users.
You start with a few,
so stop thinking big and start thinking
small hand serve your customers,
win them over one by one.
Now,
this may sound like odd advice if you're
an entrepreneur with global ambitions.
Mark Zuckerberg didn't personally
invite 1.8 billion people to Facebook.
He built a great product and
the users just poured in, right?
Not exactly on this show.
I'll dispel that myth by talking to
founders who fought to win their users.
I'm starting with Brian Chesky,
CEO of Airbnb because he epitomizes the
idea of handcrafting the user experience
before you start to scale.
It's a principal. He first
absorbed in design school.
I was doing medical design ones.
I designed a children's ventilator.
I had to sit in the shoes, the child and
so I had to like imagine being a child,
get in like the operating table and like
you have to put yourself in the shoes
of the patient where the person using
your product and if you're only doing ab
tests like you're never
designing with empathy.
But a funny thing happened to Brian
when he moved to silicon valley,
he sort of forgot about designing
with empathy for a single user.
It's a common mistake amongst
entrepreneurs with global ambitions.
They have to promise investors the world,
tens of millions of customers,
billions in revenue. It's
intoxicating. Just listen to Brian Go.
This is a travel industry
that is something like 7% of global GDP,
somewhere between five and $7 trillion
10 times the market size of Google's
market size and Brian might've stayed
in the stratosphere if not for a fateful
meeting with Paul Graham
Co founder of y Combinator.
Y Combinator is a startup incubator which
cultivates and invests in early stage
companies.
Brian was admitted to y Combinator in
2009 and his first meeting with Paul was
confounding.
Paul tends to stump people
with deceptively simple
question and he asked us,
where's your business? And I go, what do
you mean? Like where's the traction? I go,
well, we don't have a lot of traction.
He goes, well, people must be using it.
I said,
there's a few people in New York using
it and you've said something I'll never
forget. He said, sue sewer,
your users are in New York and you're
still in mountain view. I said, yeah.
He said, what are you still doing here?
And I go, what do you mean? He said,
go to your users, get to know them, get
your customers one by one. And I said,
what? That won't scale before.
Hugely millions of customers.
We can't meet every customer.
And he said,
that's exactly why you should do it now
because this is the only time you'll
ever be small enough that you
can meet all your customers,
get to know them and make
something directly for them.
Brian and his cofounders followed
his advice to the letter.
We literally community in
Newark from mountain view.
So we would be in why com era for a,
was it Tuesday night dinners and then
Wednesday Joe and I would go to New York.
We literally would knock on the doors
of all of our hosts and we had their
addresses and we say, knock,
knock, hello. Hey, this is Brian.
Joe were founders who
just want to meet you.
It's a little creepy just to
knock on the door on announced.
We need to excuse it,
like in their home.
So they came up with an offer
that the host couldn't refuse.
We'd send a professional photographer
to your home and photograph your home.
Of course, we didn't have any money and
we couldn't have played photographers.
So Joe and I, we'd show up at
their door and they're like, wow,
this company is pretty small. These home
visits became AIRBNB's secret weapon.
It's how they learned what people loved.
It's really hard to get even
10 people to love anything,
but it's not hard if you
spend a ton of time with them.
So if I want to make something amazing,
I just spend time with you. And I'm like,
well what if I did this?
What if I did this?
What if I did this from those questions?
A handcrafted experience is born.
We'd find out, hey, I don't
feel comfortable the guests,
I don't know who they are.
Well, what if we had a profiles? Great.
Well what do you want your profile?
But I want a photo. Great, what
else? I want to know where they work,
where they went to school.
Okay,
so you add that stuff and then you
literally start designing touchpoint by
touchpoint.
The creation of the peer review system,
customer support. All of these
things came from us. Literally.
We didn't just meet our users,
we live with them.
And I used to joke that
when you bought an iPhone,
Steve Jobs didn't come sleep
on your couch. But I did. Yes.
Was there a particular experience
that has really stuck in your mind?
I remember we met with a couple
of hosts and it's winter,
it's snowing outside and we're like
in snow boots and we walk up to the
apartment and we went there to
photograph the homes and we're like, Hey,
I'll upload your photos to the website.
Um, do you have any other feedback?
And he comes back a book binder
and he's got like dozens of pages of
notes and he ends up creating like a
product roadmap for us. Like we should
have this, this, this, this, this.
And we're like, oh my God, this is
our roadmap because he's the customer.
And I think that always stuck in our
mind as the roadmap often exists in the
minds of the users you're
designing things for.
And it's typical to get very detailed
feedback from some of your early users.
And if you're not getting some people
who say, this is super important to me,
I love this. I really need this to work
well. It usually means you're off track.
Passionate feedback is a clue that your
product really matters to someone and
one passionate user can turn into many.
If you listen to them carefully,
it's essential to get this kind of
feedback early while you're still defining
the product. It's like setting
a foundation. As an architect,
you wouldn't build a skyscraper before.
You've built a solid foundation user
feedback and sure as you won't build a
dozen floors on an unstable swamp.
Brian is a simple method for extracting
detailed feedback from users.
He doesn't ask what the
product he already built.
He asks about the product of the dreams.
We'd ask these questions like,
what can we do as surprise you? Like
what could we do not to make this better,
but they make you tell everyone about it
and the answer is different. If I say,
what can I do to make this better?
That they'll say something small.
If I were to say read,
what would it take for me to design
something that you would literally tell
every single person you've
ever encountered and you
start to ask these questions
and it really helps you
think through this problem.
It's essential to seek out
and listen to user feedback,
but the caveat is you have to
figure out which users to listen to.
You're going to have different kinds of
users giving you feedback and some of it
will take you in the wrong direction.
So you need to exercise
judgment and discerning, well,
this particular user and particular
feedback lead me to the mass market,
or is it an edge case?
For example,
at Linkedin we had one group of users
who invent a name for themselves.
They call themselves lions,
which is linkedin open networkers because
their theory of the world was that
everyone wants to directly connect to
everyone else in the world because that's
the way they wanted it, but they're
actually not the majority case.
A lot of people who are very busy,
how have access resources who have
some celebrity status do not want that.
And if we've followed their feedback,
linkedin would not be where it is today.
We had to steer away from a bunch
of passionate users who told us very
explicitly that we were fools
for not following their advice.
If you want to build
something that's truly viral,
you have to create a total like
experience that you tell everyone about.
And so we basically took one part of our
product and we extrapolated what would
a five star experience be?
And we went crazy. So a one,
two or three star experience is you
get to airbnb and no one's there.
So you knock on the door, they
don't open. That's the one star,
you know, and maybe it's a
three star. If they don't open,
you had to wait 20 minutes and if they
never show up and you're pissed and you
to get her money back, that's one
star you never union says again.
So a five star experience is you
knock on the door, they open the door,
they let you in. Great.
That's not a big deal.
You're not going to tell every friend
about it. You might say, I used Airbnb,
it worked. So we thought, what
would a six star experience be?
A six star experience. Knock on the
door. The host opens. Hey, I'm reed,
welcome to my house.
You're the host in this case.
And you would show them around and
on the table would be a welcome gift.
You would be a bottle of wine, maybe
some candy, you'd open the fridge,
there's water,
you go to the bathroom,
this toiletries and the whole thing is
great. That's a six star experience.
And you'd say, wow, I love
this more than a hotel.
I'm definitely gonna use airbnb again.
It worked better than I expected.
What's a seven star experience? Knock
on the door. Reid Hoffman opened.
Get in, welcome. Here's by full
kitchen. I know you like surfing,
there's a surf board waiting for you.
I booked lessons for you.
It's going to be an amazing experience.
And by the way, here's my car.
If you can use my car and um, you
know, I also want to surprise you,
but I got you. This is best restaurant
in the city of San Francisco.
I got you a table there and you're like,
whoa.
Like this is way beyond adding
stars clearly excites Brian.
It took some time to run
through this mental exercise.
We'll skip ahead to
the 10 star experience.
So would a 10 star check and be a chance.
Our check in would be the Beatles checkin
in 1964 I get off the plane and they'd
be 5,000 high school kids
cheering my name with cars,
welcoming me to the country.
I get to the front yard of your house
and they'd be a press conference for me
and I would be just a mind experience.
So what would 11 star experience be?
I would show up the airport and you'd be
there with Elon Musk and you're saying
you're going to space
the point of the processes that
maybe nine 10 11 are not feasible.
But if you go through the
crazy exercise of keep going,
there's some sweet spot between,
they showed up in the open
the door and I went to space.
That's the sweet spot and you have
to almost design the extreme to come
backwards suddenly doesn't just like
having like knowing my preferences and
having a Surf Board in the house
seem like not crazy and reasonable.
It's actually kind of crazy logistically,
but this is the kind of stuff
that creates great experience.
How far do you go toward the 11 star
experience to create the Nirvana product?
All successful entrepreneurs at some
point have to come back down to earth.
There's really two stages of a
startup's product. The first design,
a perfect experience, and then you
scale that experience and that's it.
But which part of the perfect
experience do you scale?
So the most ambitious entrepreneurs,
let's call them the Elan's,
after my friend Elon Musk probably get
there through raw energy because they're
convinced they need to solve a problem.
And the unscalable thing is one step
that they have to push through on the way
the Elan say,
I'm going to Mars,
but first I've got to solve this
problem right in front of me first.
I need to get that rocket and I need
to have a business model for that.
First rocket and that looks
like satellites. Okay,
I'm going to try satellite launches
and how do I get my first rocket?
I need to create a
scalable rocket platform.
But unless they get the first rocket up,
it doesn't matter.
And you kind of work back to that.
Then you've got folks like Brian who say,
I realize that to get
this awesome experience,
I have to ratchet back to something
that still seems like magic,
but it's totally doable.
And then I need to design the elements
that get me into the totally doable thing.
So how does Brian decide
on the doable thing?
He settled on a service with
the appropriate level of
magic and started building
it.
And here's the next thing to notice.
They didn't launch perfectly scaled
services. They built everything by hand.
We had
saying that you would do
everything by hand tools painful.
So Joe and I would photograph
home sells painful.
Then we get up at arbors that we manage
them with spreadsheets til it's painful.
Then we've got an intern.
I don't think I knew how anything
would grow to the level that it did.
That's Ellie feel. She's the intern
who manage those spreadsheets.
She still works at Airbnb
very manually.
I would email the photographer and
the host and connect to them and the
photographer would then
send me the photos. Um,
I would go through each one giving
feedback if they needed to be retouched,
and then I would manually upload
them to the hosts website.
They're listing one by one.
It would take hours to upload.
Multitasking was the name of the game,
and then we automate the tools
to make her more efficient.
And we kind of looked at this and we said,
okay,
what is the easiest thing
that we can automate?
Any little thing that changed was,
you know,
quite a shift in what I had been doing,
but for the better.
And I remember one day Brian would
come to me at the end of every day,
how many did we get, how many photos
were shot? And it was like, oh gosh,
I have to go through
and count all of these.
And then eventually a
system does everything.
We built a system where now with
the host comes, you press a button,
it alerts our system, which goes
to a dispatcher, photographers.
It's all managed through our technology.
They get the job,
they mark it through an app that
we built and then payment happens.
The whole thing is automated.
Now
note how they gradually worked out a
solution they didn't guess at what users
wanted.
They reacted to what users asked for
and then they met the demand through a
piecemeal process.
And here we come to the true art
of doing things that don't scale.
It's not just a crude way of
succeeding on a shoe string budget.
It also gives your team inspiration and
urgency to build the features that users
really want. I've seen this handcrafting
story play out over and over again with
entrepreneurs. Take my friend Patrick
Collison, he's the founding CEO,
stripe and online payments company.
Today,
thousands of businesses use stripe
to process payments from their online
customers,
but in the early days they were a
scrappy startup and Patrick paid close
attention to his users, very close
attention. We had a chat room,
uh,
where we would just help customers both
whatever issue that they wanted to ask
about.
And we were very distressed if for a
while to notice that occasionally it would
come into the chat room, Holger of
sleeping and ask a question, you know,
they wouldn't get any response.
And so we wrote a Bot,
they were just page one of us.
If somebody asks a question,
they didn't get a response after more
than 30 seconds or something and someone
would kind of groggily bleary eyed,
wake up and like help imagine and get back
to sleep. So in addition to being CEO,
Patrick had become stripe's
bleary eyed customer service rep,
frustrated users would page him at all
hours. It sure did not feel glamorous.
You just tapping away on my
laptop for half an hour in beds.
Actually that reminds me,
I don't know if you know Paul
English who founded Kayak.
Kayak is an online travel service that
finds the lowest available rates across
different websites. We noticed
a little bit. Yeah. Paul, um,
for a number of years and Kayak had
his cell phone number as the customer
service number. W we
also had one of our, uh,
there's some of that stripe two
who did exactly the same thing.
Now it's common for entrepreneurs to swap
stories like this and they think it's
worth dwelling on these early days
of handcrafted work because most
entrepreneurs tend to have a funny
reaction to these experiences.
They may laugh about it later.
They may call the work unglamorous.
They may celebrate the day.
They could hire a helping hand or
automate these chores out of existence.
But thoughtful founders will never
say what a complete waste of time.
They'll often look back on this period
as one of the most creative phases of
their careers. Nancy Lublin, for instance,
scrappily launched an
international nonprofit from
our New York City apartment.
Her Organization dress for success
started as a clothing drive for women who
needed to walk into a job interview
looking sharp and feeling confident.
Nancy stockpiled sweaters on her
bed and jewelry and refrigerator.
And soon she was inviting volunteers
into our apartment for informal training
sessions.
So people start hearing about dress
for success and would contact me.
Just random people would contact me and
say, I want to start this in St Louis.
I want to start this in
Hartford and I would say, great,
you want to come stay with me?
People literally strangers would fly
from St Louis and stay on my Futon,
my college futon in my tiny like law
school apartment in New York and I'd be
like, how can I help? And I would
send them postcards like saying like,
don't give up.
I know it's really hard.
You got this and I just
killed them with kindness.
Today dress for success has
affiliates and 145 cities worldwide.
But let's be clear,
the transition from the handcrafted
phase to the massive scale phase is a
challenging one and I wanted to spell any
illusions that you can switch from one
to the other with ease. In fact,
it requires two opposing mindsets.
You have to fully empathize with a
single user at the same time you have to
worry about everyone. I like the way
that Brian describes the difference.
The designing of experience is a different
part of your brain. Then the skilling,
your spirits.
It's a different skill set.
The scale and experience is a highly
analytical operations oriented nick tology
oriented problem.
The designing of the experience is a
more intuition based human empathetic end
to end experience.
One parallel might be writing and editing,
so the hand crafted phase
tends to be more like writing.
It's a more inventive
and creative process.
Whereas the scaling phase
tends to be more analytical.
It's more like being an editor at that
point. You tend to do more pruning.
You realize, well, this
whole thing is magical,
but if we focus on this 20%
we get 80% of the magic.
So you prune you compact,
you distill and you architect so
can now run at a rocket ship rate.
You're transitioning the product or
service over to a scale organization that
can now run it.
The organization needs a simple plan
with very few errors and very little
improvisation.
Now you might think the first step design,
the ideal user experience drops away
as soon as your product goes viral.
Then comes the glamorous work of expanding
a new countries and thinking about
your strategy in the years ahead.
Handcrafted work is essentially a kind
of booster rocket that helps you get an
orbit, but it's not the kind of
rock and for the whole trajectory.
It gets you out of the gravity well and
after that get ready to slingshot around
the world,
it became an international company.
Then middle of 2011 we raised money.
We were like this billion
dollar evaluation company
and then in summer 2011 a
woman's home got trashed and then
we had to go to the next step,
which was we are just this
little company department.
But as far as the world's concerned,
we have a giant office building.
We better be grownups.
So we had to build 24 seven support,
had to have more secure
payment instruments.
We had to add a trust and safety team.
We had to verify people's identity.
We realize we have to get our
money transmission licenses.
So then there's this
whole like administrative
bureaucracy that gets added.
Then 2012 we get to the point we are,
we have like 50 a hundred employees.
We have no executive team.
There's no management. There's
no like company meetings.
There's no communication.
So no one knows anything. Look,
literally nothing. I don't,
I don't even know how we ran the company.
And so I instituted some basic things
like I have to have an executive team and
then the lawsuits come in and
you have to really sort it out.
And unfortunately we're not regulate
the federal level regularly at the city
level. And every city is different and
they're like, I see what you did in Paris,
but here in New York were different.
I see it to go city by city and you've
got to hire those people to really triage
and deal with all these issues.
It's like a video game.
You slay a dragon,
you think you've completed the board game,
and then you have the next level and all
of a sudden the dragons get really big.
But when you're slaying dragons,
it's hard to hold onto the
handcrafted mindset still.
I would argue that the sharpest founders
never fully abandoned the mindset,
no matter how big their company goes.
And so the organization will start having
antibodies against new handcrafted.
Then it's a response that protects
organizational efficiency. It says,
look, this new thing, we can't get
it to scale. It won't operationalize.
It won't fit within our process.
The reason the scaled companies have a
hard time with is handcrafted process is
all in the list of objections
about why this won't work,
why this shouldn't be integrated
as part of the company.
And so what you need to do as a founder
is be extremely choiceful about which
handcrafted you choose and how
you protect it. Organizationally.
You need to protect it because the
natural reaction of the scale organization
will be to kill it.
He wanted to reinvent the industry again
and he knew he had more to learn about
the travel experience in order to do it.
So he turned to Hollywood for help.
I often find that to reinvent an industry,
you're not taking inspiration
directly from that industry,
that you need to look at
orthogonal industries and for us,
the orthogonal industry to travel with
cinema and the best ships you've ever
seen are the trips that characters and
movies have and that we would provide
that analogy in real life.
And I actually literally
hired a storyboard artist
and Pixar and we had them
storyboard the perfect airbnb experience.
When we did that,
we realized there was like this two hour
movie and only 20 minutes we're in the
home. There was all this like leading
up to the home, getting the airport,
going around, going to dinner, hanging out
with friends out and about and be like,
most of the trip was not in the home,
but we realize that point we need to be
in the end to end business of travel.
So the same way that he did things that
don't scale, we call them magical trips.
We decided let's find one traveler
and create the perfect trip for them.
Notice how quickly Brian
turns his attention to a
single traveler in an instant.
He switches from global concerns back
to is artisanal roots and that's because
he's building something radically new
here. He wants to scale the perfect trip,
but what is the perfect trip?
What are the essential ingredients
that make a vacation truly memorable?
It's a question that Brian can't even
begin to answer until he delivers that
experience to at least one person.
You're about to get a
masterclass in handcrafting.
So we put up these flyers
as anonymously saying,
seeking a traveler will photograph your
trip to San Francisco if you let us
follow you. This guy,
Martin Ricardo replied,
he was from London and we send a
photographer around him while he was just
traveling to San Francisco.
What we learned was his trip was awful.
Like he'd show up,
he'd go to Alcatraz by himself,
put on the headset and then you go to
Bubba Gump shrimp. He'd stay in like, uh,
like budget hotel.
He'd go to a hotel bar by himself,
like sitting like with a
bunch of dudes at the bar
and talk to anyone cause he's introverted.
We call them back. You say, Ricardo,
we want to create the perfect
trip to San Francisco for you.
You fly him back and we
had the team storyboard,
the perfect experience for Airbnb.
We had a driver pick them up the airport
and we took them to the perfect airbnb.
They're all these services.
He went on these dinner parties,
we got in the best seats at restaurant.
We took them on as
midnight mystery bike tour,
like 60 riders go on it and nobody,
but the leader knows what.
We'll end up and it's just like
there was this crazy, magical world.
I see him at the end of the trip.
I say, how was your trip? He says,
it was amazing, and then I
walk away, yells at me, Brian,
one more thing and starts like crying
and he breaks down a thank you.
This is the best trip I've ever
had. I was like, oh my God.
I guess it kind of kind of worked like
it really moved him because I don't think
anyone ever tried to like design end to
end experience or somebody like they're
in a movie before and we did it.
That became a blueprint and we said,
we are confident on an unscalable basis
that we know how to create a trip that
deeply moves somebody is better than
anything they've ever experienced.
The question is, can we
develop a technology scales
and do 100 million times?
Notice here how quickly Brian
Switches back to the analytic mindset.
He can extrapolate from a single journey
to a list of essential ingredients.
Here's the systematic
breakdown of the perfect trip.
When you first go to city,
you need a welcome event
within the first 24 48 hours.
We are around people. When you land and
you get acclimated to the neighborhood,
that by day two or three, you need to
have a challenge out of your comfort zone.
If you do not leave your comfort zone,
you do not remember the trip, okay?
And if you can belong out of your comfort
zone and something new happens to you,
then there's going to be
a moment of transformation
where the person you were in
a small way dies at a new,
better version of yourself is reborn.
Now, this is the narrative of
every movie you've ever seen.
A main character starts in the ordinary
world. They leave their ordinary world,
they cross the threshold to a new magical
world where all these obstacles happen
and the overcome something and
they call it the hero's journey.
And we applied this to trips,
build a small team,
and we spent the last couple of
years figuring out how to scale this.
And this has led to what we have today,
which we call airbnb trips.
In November of 2016 Brian unveiled 500
ship packages in 12 cities and now he's
fully in the scaling mindset,
figuring out how to expand the
service to new destinations.
But as Brian will tell you,
he misses the handcrafted work.
Here's a surprising message
for entrepreneurs who have
only a handful of users
to serve.
I kind of tell a lot entrepreneurs who
don't have traction, I miss those times.
I mean it,
yes,
it's exciting to have traction and have
a super sense like companies like huge
scale, but the biggest leaps you
ever get as when you're small.
And another way of saying it
is your product changes less.
The bigger you get because there's
bigger, more customers, more below back,
more systems,
more legacy.
The most innovative leaps you'll ever
make often, especially for your network,
are going to be when you're really,
really small,
you can change the protocol
a whole entirely in a week.
Try doing that at Linkedin or airbnb
today, that'd be a huge disaster.
So I think taking
advantage of that subscale,
designing the perfect experience, asking
yourself what you could do is amazing.
And if you have a teeny startup,
good news for you now is the moment you
can take the most daring leaps to your
career.
Dream big and act small.
Pay Passionate attention to your users,
handcraft the core service for them,
create magical experience
and then figure out what part of that
magical handcrafted thing can scale.
I'm Reid Hoffman.
Thank you for listening.
Masters of scale is a wait.
What original?
Our executive producers are
June Cohen and Darren triff.
Our producers are Dan [inaudible],
Jennie Cataldo and Ben Manilla.
Special thanks to Jessica Johnston.
Say this. Epi ever. Elisa Schreiber,
Chris Shea, David Sanford, j Punjabi,
Stephanie Kent and Rufina Ahmad Original
Music is by the Holladay mothers mixing
and mastering by Brian Pugh visit masters
of skill.com to find the transcript
for this episode.
Hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other
world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends, for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend,
so if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour workweek.com that's
four hour work week.com all spelled out
and just drop in your email and you will
get the very next one if you sign up.
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by audible.
Audible has the largest selection of
audio books on the planet and I've used
audible for many,
many years.
I have several books to recommend right
off the bat. Ready player one by Ernest,
climb the Tao of Seneca by Seneca.
If you want to hear my
favorite letters of all time,
put into compilation the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman.
If you're a nonfiction purist and
you want something to convert you,
this is one I've listened to multiple
times and right now if you're curious and
I'm listening to nonviolent communication
by Marshall Rosenberg and you can tell
which one is the correct one because a
peace sign on the cover of the audio book
and it's five hours and nine minutes long.
This was recommended to me by
Neil Strauss multiple time,
New York Times bestselling author and
audible has a lot going for it right now.
Among other things,
this is time sensitive.
Amazon prime members can get
audible for just four 95 a month.
That's $4 and 95 cents per month
for the first three months.
That's like getting three months for the
price of one and after that it's just
1495 per month.
This offer ends July 31st,
2018 to claim this offer,
you can go to audible.com/tim or texts
Tim t I m two 500 500 to get started.
Audible members get a credit every month,
good for any audience regardless of
price and unused credits rollover.
To the next month.
If you don't like I give an audio book
that you've purchased or that you've
selected, you can exchange
it with no hassle whatsoever.
Plus your audio books are yours to
keep forever. Even if you cancel.
Audio books are a great psychic,
a great secondary activity for any number
of things you might do this summer,
like hiking, sunbathing, hanging out
on the beach, running, road, tripping,
whatever it might be,
hiking outside.
I listened to audio books a lot when I'm
going on. Long walks, dog walks, cooking,
et cetera. Even working out
in between sets and so on.
If you're someone who likes to binge,
this offer might be a good time to start
series like game of Thrones, potter,
Outlander. The list goes
on and on, so again,
simply go to audible.com/tim or texts
Tim Tim to 500 500 to get started today.
Amazon prime members can get audible
for $4 95 cents per month for the first
three months.
Once again,
that's like getting three months for the
price one and after that it's just 1495
per month. This offer ends
July 31st, 2018 check it out.